I Steve Kaufman here to talk again about
language learning my passion one of my
passions thank you for all of those who
commented you know this campaign we have
what would you like to talk to me about
with regard to language learning I may
very well incorporate some of these
questions in future videos but we are
gonna have a draw on February the 2nd to
see who is going to actually sit down
with me and discuss these things if you
enjoy my videos please subscribe today I
want to talk about giving yourself the
benefit of the doubt and I'm gonna
explain to you what that means and I
think that's very important in language
learning if not in life you know I sit
there and I work on my Arabic so I read
listen don't always fully understand I
do our activities of link flashcards
multiple-choice dictation to kind of get
into the words and phrases that appear
in the lesson I'm doing it both in you
know sentence view and then the whole
lesson and and you know there are times
when I might question you know will I
ever learn this language will I ever get
to a point where I can actually
understand this language and so I say to
myself of course I will in others I give
myself the benefit of the doubt if I
stay with it long enough if I continue
doing what I'm doing
I will learn the language and I use this
principle in a variety of ways for
example one of the things I do at link
is I go through the lesson and I pick
words that I now kind of more or less
know or at least understand in context
and I move them to known I'm a little
I'm getting ahead of myself a bit I
wouldn't be able to use those words in
speaking in fact I can't speak in Arabic
but I'm moving them along because then
when I look at a page at link there are
fewer yellow words and there are more
white words that presumably are known I
focus in on the ones that I still don't
understand even in context but I give
myself the benefit of the doubt there's
no big risk there because if I come
across a word that
don't understand I just save it again so
that there's no damage but it also gives
me a sense of confidence oh look at me
you know I've increased my known word
count mine own word counted link in
Arabic is up to five or six hundred
words probably a lot of those I wouldn't
even understand if I saw them might have
trouble reading them but I'm giving
myself the benefit of the doubt and I
have found that to be a good strategy so
these words that I keep forgetting will
they ever you know really sock in there
so that I I recognize them and I can use
them I have no doubt to think what that
I will that they will eventually stick I
give myself the benefit of the doubt and
I think this is very important when
we're speaking for example if okay
Arabic I can't really speak but language
says that I speak if I'm forever second
guessing myself is this the correct
former is that the correct form I just
give myself the benefit of the dog
whatever phrase pops into my mind as I'm
speaking I try to use it you know how
did I do did I speak well or did I not
speak well forget it give yourself the
benefit of the doubt you know that's not
to say you won't make mistakes you will
but you're better off not questioning
yourself you're better off to just go
with it and I mean if you think for
example I was in a taxi in Vancouver and
the taxi driver was originally from Iran
and he said when they emigrated to
Canada and his son was six years old and
went to school and he was afraid and
couldn't speak and stuff and within a
few months the teacher wrote a letter to
this bond this father saying your kid is
talking too much in class in other words
a kid just fitted in he wasn't doubting
whether he could communicate very
quickly he was communicating and so I
think that is in an important sort of
attitude to have to give yourself the
benefit of the doubt and I think too
often even like like teachers fuss too
much and they want to protect kids or
they you know I remember for example
when I first started into creating a
language learning platform I was
involved with immigrants to Vancouver
China and I said well you know maybe we
should set up a program where these kids
who live in a very you know in an area
Vancouver there are lots of Chinese kids
send them to the interior to some small
town to a camp living with family or
whatever say the cow boot and of course
the the Chinese ethnic Association said
well you know a Chinese family would
never let their kids go to a camp like
that because there's no multicultural
associate you know
infrastructure in those little towns
yeah the kid will do just fine don't
worry about a multicultural
infrastructure in fact there's all kinds
of Chinese families that send their kids
to Vancouver put them in Park them in a
high school and they live in China and
the kids are left to fend for themselves
you know again that's pretty typical by
the way that any of these sort of
interest groups that have an
organization the spokespeople for the
organization claim to speak for the
whole community whereas in fact if you
polled the community you'd find that
these leaders of the you know Chinese
ethnic Association aren't necessarily
represented but that's another issue so
I give yourself the benefit the note
don't and give learners the benefit of
the doubt and I think this is important
in life like if I think back to when I
was young so many times I hesitated if I
just give myself the benefit of the
doubt and go for it what's the worst
case the worst case is probably still
going to be better than if you doubt
yourself so tip of the day if you want
when it comes to language learning and
other things give yourself the benefit
of the doubt you may be quite pleasantly
surprised by for now
hi there hi I'm back here give myself
the benefit of the doubt I had one of my
viewers who teaches Arabic Sudanese
pieces English to Syrian refugees wanted
me to say something in Arabic I can't
really say anything in Arabic but I can
try to read remember my focus in
learning any languages to go three
months six months listening and reading
before I actually start speaking but I
thought I'd just give us try reading in
arabic for me at least is it easy
because it's not obvious how the you
know where the vowel slot in and so
forth but we'll give it a try see what
happens Heather hey Kissick Achmed
elderly Yama taboc I've met who works as
a cook yes they could Ahmed Khan Sabah
Phil saw a save ISA gets up every
morning at 6:00 yeah hunter al father
makes breakfast
Wow yeah sure yeah shareable kava kava
he drinks coffee
what's that not yeah cool yeah yeah cool
yeah cool
sorry senorita Aliyah drives to work um
yep da fiel ha sabbia sabbia one oops
Saba I think I don't do that's enough of
massacring the Arabic language I hope
that's encouraging to these learners we
all struggle but if we give ourselves
the benefit of the doubt we will
eventually get there we just have to
stay with the program bye for now
[Music]